neighbors filmed the moment soldiers
opened fire on a religious sect as they
prepared to go to a protest in Goma
leaders of a Christian animus group had
urged followers to overrun U.N bases and
demand that peacekeepers leave Congo
there's anger over the Congolese
military's brutal Crackdown on unarmed
civilians for us we need Justice because
Congolese Army either to protect Congo
and to protest Congolese the national
Army is not there to kill civilians and
to kill Congolese they are strong their
strengths have to be demonstrated
against rebellions like M23 that who are
in Congo right now
government trips have been dispersing
civilians at anti-un protests for months
including the band demonstration on
Wednesday
many congoles blame the U.N peacekeeping
mission monasco for failing to stop the
violence after more than two decades
operating in the region its mandate ends
in December but it hasn't specified an
exit date
we were going to protest peacefully but
we were surprised to be surrounded by
the Army at night they didn't arrest us
instead they started shooting with live
bullets without any reason
the government enforced a circled state
of Siege or martial law in north kivo
and eturi provinces in the East
Democratic Republic of Congo since 2021
it aims to crush multiple Rebel groups
vying for control over resource-rich
areas
the fighting has resulted in killings
and displacements of thousands of people
in the region now the government's
facing criticism for using excessive
force against its own people
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera